maintenance of expertise which one
doesn't normally get at these uh at
workshops or meetings in any case what
i'd like to do today is uh tell you
about our ongoing work uh to map genetic
interaction networks and the real goal
here like most of the work that we've
been describing at this meeting is to
contribute to the mapping of the
genotype to phenotype relationship
and we want to use information we get
from mapping networks in model systems
to help discover potentially principles
that would allow us to more cogently map
genetic networks and more complex
organisms such as human cell lines for
example
so i'll start by giving you an overview
of our east genetic interaction network
project because it provides the
essential foundation for unpublished
work where we started to explore a
scaffold genetic interaction network in
a human cell line and hopefully all time
at the end since we've been discussing a
lot of these things and actually your
talk brought up some unsupervised
clustering methods where we're trying to
integrate our automated genetics
platform with single cell imaging so
that instead of using a fitness-based
readout we can get uh multi-parametric
phenotypic profiles and that'll allow
because it's single cell image we can
explore not only gene function but
penetrance of genetic mutations and
pleiotropy which pascal was talking
about in his talk so we'll see how far i
get i'm i wouldn't i don't want to dig
into your time for being outside on this
wonderful day anyway i don't tell this
audience about the importance of
developing systematic methods to explore
the genotype to phenotype relationship
and really our interest here is
exploring the role of genetic
interactions in this in this
relationship
and the big groundwork that we've been
working on for well over 15 years now is
to map a reference genetic interaction
network in the budding yeast using
reagents that are available for doing
systematic genetics and this hasn't been
discussed yet but although we've had a
couple of yeast talks
the reason that we were able to start
contemplating doing this in yeast is
because of the availability of reagents
for doing uh forward genetic screens
which includes an array of five thousand
uh mutant strains each deleted for a
non-essential gene so single mutants
there and then a mutant arrays that
allow us to query the function of
essential genes and so our lab and
others have made a variety of these
collections the one that we use in these
projects uh contain hypomorphic or
temperature sensitive alleles of
essential genes so even this result
though that you can delete any one of 5
000 genes in yeast and you don't kill
the cell for example illustrates that
there is genetic redundancy here and in
order to begin to address that we reason
that we should be able to develop we
should develop some method for
automating yeast genetics so that we can
use these arrays and make double immune
to rays so then we can explore the
difference in phenotype between the
single mutants and the double mutants
and start to build genetic interaction
networks
so many years ago we developed a method
called synthetic genetic array or sga
analysis which does automate yeast
genetics and it allows us to introduce
any marked allele of a gene of interest
into these yeast mutant arrays or any
other immune array that you have
available and so in the case of the
project i'm describing today we're using
sga to make double immune to rays which
we then are going to assess for unusual
uh phenotypes and specifically we're
assessing for genetic interactions and
this occurs when an allele of one gene
combines with the allele of another gene
to generate an unexpected double mutant
phenotype and so we can use any any
phenotype in theory to measure a genetic
interaction including subcellular
morphology phenotypes which i hope i'll
get to later but by far the easiest and
most scalable phenotype to assay in
yeast is
cell growth and we can do this very
easily in an array-based format by
measuring the colony size of single
mutants simply by taking pictures of
arrays and looking at them and measuring
the number of pixels associated with the
colony and then we can measure the
colony size of the double mutant and
then ask if that deviates from expected
based on the single immune phenotypes
super easy easy to scale and
quantitative so this is what we've been
focusing on a lot and getting back to
your pointers about non-additive effects
what we're testing here is a
multiplicative model where we expect
that the double mutant will show both of
the phenotypes associated with the
single mute and so we expect for example
if a single mutant reduces fitness by 30
or so and another single mutant by 30 50
if we combine both mutations in the same
cell we expect to see the multiplicative
effect of these two uh single immunes so
we expect 35 percent the growth of wild
type and anything that deviates from
this we would score as a genetic
interaction a so-called negative class
where the double mutant is growing less
well than expected based on the single
mutant phenotypes the most dramatic
example of that is synthetic lethality
which we've heard people mention several
times in the context of cancer for
example but we can also score positive
genetic interactions also a very
interesting class of genetic
interactions particularly from a human
disease gene
genetics perspective so we can
score positive interactions including
these dramatic uh interactions where the
strain is growing better than the
worst growing single mutant
so anyway about six years ago now we
published a complete reference genetic
interaction network for budding yeast
where we tested most of the 6000 genes
in yeast for possible pairwise genetic
interactions
this project has been led throughout by
michael costanza a senior research
associate in our group and michael
identified nearly a million interactions
uh 550 000 negative interactions and 350
000 positive interactions and this
network spans about 90 percent of of all
yeast genes so it's reasonably complete
amongst the negative genetic
interactions there's about 10 000
synthetic lethal interactions so these
are double mutant combinations where uh
the double mutant is dead and again this
sort of defines genetic background
specific gene essentiality which is
something that's interesting to explore
for example in other strains of yeast
that we heard about
from andreas where we might be able to
ask do we see differences in essential
gene sets and different background
backgrounds and can we define the
genetic effects that underlie that
dramatic phenotype it's also an
important consideration for people
interested in designing synthetic
genomes it's important to know what
kinds of combinations you you can't make
so what about genetic network properties
i motivated this by saying we wanted to
find features of the network that we
might
might be useful for exploring networks
and human cells for example and to
discover these kinds of features the way
we display our data typically is to
generate genetic interaction profiles
for each of the query genes so genetic
interactions are rare so most most of
the genes don't interact with your query
but you'll see some positive and
negative interactions associated with
each gene mutation and that's its
genetic interaction profile and then we
simply group or cluster those genetic
interaction profiles together and look
for high correlation modules in our data
so we're looking for genes that when
mutated share genetic interactions in
common and we reason that this would
likely
identify genes who are who are
performing related functions that was
the sort of major hypothesis going in
and we can display these data in a
number of ways but we just simply use
a network display where the nodes are
the nodes are the genes that we've taken
through the sga process and they're
connected by edges that reflect the
degree to which they share genetic
interactions in common so things that
are real close together on the network
share a lot of genetic interactions in
common and you can dial that up and down
depending on on how stringent you want
to be
so this is a picture of the global all
by all similarity network uh for the for
for the budding east looking at double
mutants in a fitness based readout and i
think without annotation you can clearly
see there are clusters of correlated
genetic interaction profiles on the
network and then we can uh functionally
annotate it using various means and for
example here we're functionally
annotating the net
work using gene ontology bio process
terms and we can see about 500 terms
that are enriched on the network and
they tend to map to 17 unique network
regions or clusters on the diagram and
you can't see this but these correspond
to the major bioprocesses of within the
eukaryotic cell such as ribosome
biogenesis physical trafficking
cytokinesis peroxisome function
respirative oxidative phosphorylation
etc so we're clearly able to using this
kind of genetic interaction profile
approach identify bioprocesses within
the yeast cell and we reason that the
you know the position and connectivity
on these networks would likely help us
to predict for example the function of
uncharacterized genes we can also use
other functional annotation standards to
explore the network for example here
we're looking at a subpart of the
network only now we're using a protein
complex standard and we're demanding
that the genetic interaction profiles
are more similar between the genes and
in this case we clearly start to see
major protein complexes that we know
were involved in for example
transcription
and dna damage and repair
so there's a very high correlation
between known protein complexes with
correlated genetic interaction profiles
between these mutants and then you can
demand less correlation and use as a
protein localization standard see if
there's any enrichment on the network
and indeed we see that so for example we
can annotate with a standard that was
based on gfp fusion protein localization
in yeast and we see regions of the
network that correspond to the major
subcellular compartments such as nucleus
nuclear periphery et cetera
so to me this was kind of remarkable at
the time and what michael
dubbed this was a functional wiring
diagram the cell or a hierarchical model
of cell function where we can make these
networks and then functionally annotate
them to re reveal different layers or
levels of functional mean information
like cell compartments bioprocess and
pathways up not pathways protein
complexes and sub modules
anyway so this is sort of the background
um and so what we wanted to do was also
look within these this information to
see if we can see any properties in the
network that we could use to start to
map the human cell and this is one that
i i like to show because it's uh turns
out to be a motif that we see recurring
in the human network that we're working
on and that is that when we look at
genes uh that when we uh that encode
components of known and well-conserved
protein complexes for example the 19s
proteasome here and we're looking at
both the positive and negative genetic
interactions that this components of the
proteasome have we see very coherent
interactions with other conserved
protein complexes such as the dna
replication factor c the compass complex
abc trap etc and we we sort of say
coherent because they tend to be all
negative or all positive genetic
interactions that we see between
components of the proteasome and other
complexes and we see this kind of
pattern duplicated when we look at other
protein complexes throughout the network
so that was kind of a striking motif
which we thought that we could try to
use to pick query genes that we might
use to map a scaffold network in human
cells so that's one thing i'll come back
to in a bit
and of course we can start to look at
networks and human cells because we can
now do genome-scale genome editing
screens where we can make
loss-of-function mutations simply by
using libraries of guide rnas to target
all the genes for example in the human
genome and we've been using the uh we've
been doing this for the last few years
in collaboration with our colleague in
the donald center jason moffitt who has
set up a pipeline for doing these crispr
caspase screens and we have to choose a
reference cell line and we could argue
about this forever but the cell line
that we've been using as a hap one cell
line that
was introduced to you earlier this
morning
and so the challenge is massive though
of course i've just told you about yeast
a project that took us 15 years where we
did an all by all map of the 6 000 genes
double genes and their double mutes in
humans the the scope of the problem is
much larger and so we again this is
what's motivating us to kind of try to
go back and forth from yeast to human
cells to take a logical approach to
approaching this problem maximize the
amount of information we're going to get
from each screen that we do it's time
consuming and expensive so again this
was to apply the rules learned from
yeast to efficiently map interactions
for key human uh genes
and so the most important thing uh
predictor of whether or not you're a
network hub a genetic network hub that
is you're going to have lots of genetic
interactions is whether or not the
single mutant has a fitness defect so
essential genes are clear hubs on the
genetic interaction network they're a
little bit harder harder to study as
queries and yeast we have reagents in
human cells not so much as queries
and also non-essential genes that have a
fitness defect so if a single mutant
already has a fitness defect to start
with it will give you a lot more genetic
interactions than one that doesn't at
least using a fitness-based readout so
the first thing we wanted to do was
discover these non-essential fitness
genes in the hap1 cell model so that we
could then make queries and start doing
genetic interaction screening and so to
make that catalog katie chan um
supervised a technical team in the lab
that simply did about 40 different uh
genome-wide screens in the hap1 parental
cell line looking and then just
following the dropout of guides as we
outgrow these cells and so we of course
see a large number we see a few thousand
i'll show you this in a second genes
that we'd define as essential because
they drop out very quickly from the
population and then a number of
different genes that are non-essential
sick mutants and we can quantify that
and then of course some things that
don't change at all so we wouldn't
choose those to do our screens so having
done this many many times and
controlling for guide quality and all
this stuff we see about
1568 essential genes in the human
hapland cell line this is comparable to
the you know the number of essential
genes people see in a bunch of cancer
cell lines for example on the cancer
debt map and there's a very large
overlap between the core essential gene
sets that people see in all of these
different cell lines and a couple
thousand of non-essential genes that
have a significant fitness defect so we
did indeed narrow it down but still
that's a couple of thousand and so we've
applied some other criteria to make to
come up with a couple hundred
mutants that we might like to make to
begin mapping our scaffold network and
so we did the non-essential fitness
genes obviously they have to be
expressed we started to choose
functionally diverse genes so that we
could cover a lot of bioprocesses as
we're starting to build out the scaffold
and then we also threw in a few
conserved genes of unknown function so
that we can start to explore these
unmapped functional
areas of the human genome so to speak so
we kind of came up with a list of a
couple of hundred genes that we thought
we would begin to do screens with to
start to build out our map and so the
general protocol is quite
straightforward we just use crispr cast
based guide rna
disruption to make mutant query cell
lines in these genes that we've chosen
and then we simply repeat the screen
that i just described in these different
mutant backgrounds and there's always
wild type controls we keep doing them
over and over again so we'll have the
ability just like in yeast to compare
the single mutant fitness from our wild
type screens dropout screens to the
double mutant fitness that we see in the
different query cell lines
that's the assay and of course it's a
it's a next-gen sequencing readout of
the barcodes and their abundance in the
population
so as always figuring out the batch
effects and scoring these data our off
is often a real bottleneck at the
beginning of these projects and max
billman who was a postdoctoral fellow in
our collaborator chad myers lab at the
university of minnesota has done a great
job of looking through our data and
developing a score that we feel quite
comfortable in terms of calling genetic
interactions from these data he accounts
there's a lot of data normalization
steps including identifying and removing
frequent flyers batch correction which
is a huge problem always and of course a
lot of guide rna qc has gone on
throughout the whole process
the frequent flyers mitochondrial genes
there's some things that appear in all
the screens
yeah
so and so we we've done a couple of a
hundred of these genome-wide screens
with 108 uh unique query mutant cell
lines and so far this project has given
us three million double mutants and
eighty thousand genetic interactions and
so it's nowhere near the yeast network
yet but we can still start to ask do we
see any structures that remind us of
what we see in the yeast network so i'll
show you that data and this has been
done by henry ward a graduate student in
chad's lab i should have mentioned at
the beginning all of our computational
work on genetic networks is an ongoing
very productive collaboration with chad
myers and his team
anyway henry did this work and so all he
did was make profile genetic profile
similarity matrix using the exact same
approach we used in yeast and here's the
matrix that he he's developed so far
there's about 4200 genes on this network
so far and they're mostly on the array
side right because the
query strain side is quite sparse at
this point but we're still getting genes
onto the network because they interact
with the query genes and again i hope
you can appreciate that we are starting
to see clusters of correlated genetic
interaction profiles on the network
which is exactly what we were seeing in
yeast and then we can go ahead and try
to functionally annotate the network as
we did in yeast and this is a bio
process annotation that michael michael
did where he
used just an unbiased annotation
algorithm to identify 44 network
clusters that were enriched for gene
ontology bioprocess terms we were
talking about this yesterday that
because of the the gene ontologies
not as well developed in human cells as
in yeast michael then did some manual
annotation because some of the gene
ontology bioprocess terms were basically
identifying the same thing so he merged
various domains and ended up with 27
domains on this um on this network that
correspond again just like we saw in
these two major bioprocesses in in the
cell so we think that this kind of
approach is going to be useful for
mapping out the genetic interaction
network in human cells as well
well what about those network structures
that i was hinting about
do we have enough data can we start to
see these kind of coherent structures in
the human cell data and this is totally
fun because this gets to what we were
talking about that you can start to look
in more detail at these kinds of things
and then really
you get clues where you that prompt you
to do mechanistic experiments so you can
actually start with this very high level
data and quite quickly come up with
specific hypotheses that if you're
interested in exploring you can so i
don't want to belabor this since i only
have about five minutes left or so um
but i'll just try to tell so this is a
network motif surrounding uh the ptar-1
gene in in human cells which encodes uh
conserved protein panel transferase
alpha subunit and it normally puts uh
jeremy jurenyl residues onto its target
proteins and it shows uh these sort of
coherent patterns of negative or
positive genetic interactions with a
variety of protein complexes and one of
the most dramatic motifs is sort of a
interactions with things involved in
vesicle trafficking and intercellular
transport things like that like a whole
bunch of snares uh the corvette complex
etc so there's on the cog complex for
example
now that's cool because it suggests
these network motifs exist so we looked
back in our yeast data so this is an
example of the human data motive
motivating us to look back at east and
the yeast a version of ptar1 is called
ecm-9 ptar is not essential ecm-9 is
essential in yeast so this was done with
a ts allele and we see the same thing we
see genetic interactions with snares and
other genes and or protein complexes
involved in intracellular vesicle
transport etc what was kind of
interesting too as we saw this and we
thought well
can we get any clues about what these
genetic interactions are mean for the
biology underlying these uh journal
transferases and because ecm-9 is
essential do we have another project we
were looking for deletion mutants that
can bypass the function of essential
genes in yeast and we found an unknown
open reading frame that completely
bypasses the requirement of ecm-9 for
viability and yeast and then we go and
we look at this particular gene it
doesn't matter what it's called ynl 320
e and w or something and it encodes a
pulmonal transferase which and we
started to look at ykt6 uh the ecm-9 in
yeast and we can see that it's
palmitated at very low levels in
wild-type cells but when you get rid of
that suppressor you see the palm
mutilation go way up so we hypothesize
that normally um this this parental
transferase adrenal gerenyl transferase
is hitting its targets and activating
things and secretion go on normally when
that's perturbed uh these this sort of
other mechanism the palmital transferees
can take over and remarkably when you
look now back at the human network we
see these positive genetic interactions
with two genes that encode deep
pulmonises in human cells i don't know i
really like this example because it
shows how leveraging both networks and
going back and forth between these
models can really prompt you to explore
kind of deep mechanistic
questions
about this kind of post-translational
modification
okay so i don't really have a lot of
time left but i'm i am going to be
around all day tomorrow i'm just going
to throw you a teaser of what i kind of
wanted to talk about but i hope that
i've shown you that these i think it's
useful to map reference genetic
interaction networks and we can argue
about you know tissue specificity and
whatnot but everything we know from
yeast uh suggests that having a
reference network is going to be useful
right so that we can try to understand
or focus our efforts on looking at what
might be different in other situations
we've also as i mentioned at the
beginning uh used a single cell image
analysis automated image analysis to
explore uh changes in the sub-cellular
morphology of various compartments in
the in the east mutant collections and
and the reason we this is an important
thing to do is there are a subset of
query genes that don't yield great gi
profiles using a fitness based readout
and of course that's a population level
measurement we're using any information
about single cell variability which is a
pretty important thing when trying to
understand the genotype to phenotype
relationship so that's why we've sort of
done this and we've undertaken a marker
project where we've adapted the sga
platform to introduce fluorescent
markers of these various subsoil
compartments into the yeast mutant
collections then we image them and use
automated image allows us to identify uh
morphological outliers or phenotypes
associated with it so far most of our
work has been on single means but we
want to go ahead and start testing
selectively double mutes to see if we
get new information about genetic
interactions by using these different
readouts so we did we published a paper
i'll just put this up here a couple
years ago looking at endocytosis markers
and in this case because it was a very
uh specific bio process we were able to
build a training set by looking in the
literature and basically looking at the
images and we could build a training set
of what phenotypes we thought we were
seeing in our outliers so we make do
outlier detection we find phenotypes and
we make classifiers that identify all
these phenotypes
so that worked for this project we were
able to identify about 17 different
morphological phenotypes and related to
things that pascal was talking about
earlier a morphological pleotropy is
quite prevalent although some mutants
only affect one marker most mutants
affect more than one marker and also
incomplete penetrance is the rule rather
than the exception and actually you can
make penetrance profiles that will that
provide extra phenotypic information
than just whether or not something has a
phenotype so we've explored possible
factors underlying incomplete penetrance
so now we have this big data set though
and it's just not practical uh if we
want to ask what are the possible
morphological phenotypes associated with
genetic perturbation in in this cell
these supervised approaches simply don't
scale well there are some compartments
for which we have not much information
in the literature and to make these
training sets would be first of all
biased and and just almost impossible to
do although we have some training data
so we wanted unsupervised phenotypic
detection which may allow identification
of unexpected phenotypes and also it's
very clear that subtle by biological
significant effects with variable
penetrance might not be easy to detect
with some sort without an unsupervised
approach so i'm going to stop because
actually it's a very much an ongoing
project i'll tell you what we have tried
the beginning is the same we make our
mutant arrays we've tested various
outlier detection and feature extraction
methods we find that using cell profiler
features and segmentation is the best
way to do things for this type of
project so far although that could be
played with we've tried deep learning
features too
we've made a couple of classifiers that
get rid of garbage cells that are not
segmented properly and because it's cell
morphology which changes with the cell
cycle we also use cell cycle classifiers
and then we do outlier detection like i
told you we tested various types of
features and various types of methods
and we've settled on a gaussian mixture
model method for doing our outlier
detection so we get all the outliers
from all of these different strains and
then now we want to classify them or
cluster them in an unsupervised way to
see how many phenotypes are in there so
these are some penetrance profiles and i
think right away you can see that there
these are all the different mutants that
we've taken through the the screen these
are some of the different markers and
you can see that there are some mutants
that seem to just affect all of the
markers and actually these tend to be
essential genes some of which are just
dye you know so there's various things
we have to remove in order to uh reveal
the underlying biology
and so we've tried nmf uh to try to
cluster these data and other
unsupervised clustering approaches um i
don't have time to go into it it's
really hard
for us to know what's the best way to do
this in order to detect useful
information biologically relevant
information so that's the real
bottleneck for us right now we're trying
various things removing the cell cycle
removing the essential genes
to see if we start to make more
biological sense of these data i'd be
delighted to talk with anybody about
ideas of how to analyze these data and
also to collaborate with people who
might be interested in analyzing these
data again i've been talking about work
that's mainly been done by neil sahin a
graduate student in the lab and moits
and matias
a former postdoctoral fellow in the lab
carlos pons in the alloy lab has been
involved in analyzing these marker
project data it's super fun and quaid
morris was a collaborator on all of the
automated image analysis and there's a
large number of people that worked on
the genetic networks including the yeast
networks and the human networks and i
tried to mention key people when i was
showing the slides thank
have you considered using paralyzed
crisper screens rather than no one guide
rna one
yeah we've considered it it rapidly
comes with a problem with the library
size and the scaling which you have to
do
we've done it on a more focused level
for example to test some of the
interactions we see in other cell lines
then you can do it but to do it on this
large scale it rapidly becomes
just in too many too many cells which
becomes a ridiculously large library
so for the unsupervised uh classroom so
how do you assess whether something is
biologically developed indeed
you're just not very think what we know
you could well use supervised methods
well we you could use a supervised
method but then you'd have to have some
sort of training so we'd like to avoid
that we could do it
um
for some of the markers for example like
we did for endocytosis
right so what we've been doing is
looking at these various clusters and
looking at the cells looking at any
enrichment for bioprocess or some sort
of functional information that's in
there and we see it
right but
that doesn't really
give you enough information like i don't
i'm not comfortable looking at that
cluster and saying there are 463
different morphological phenotypes that
are possible
and i'd like to be able to say that but
i i'm not sure how to get there yeah but
still it's using
see in all these genetic models you talk
about non-f additivity that's default
non-additivity
for example for growth you take the
growth rate in the exponential
you take images of the plates that set
times after you plate them
and then you can measure the colony size
by the set time right so you're
measuring the colony size of the double
single mutants and the doubling
it's actually a remarkable quantity
we've done some comparisons with the
liquid growth assets
so okay let's say it's called inside
if you take all your n million pairs
and say you know
what is your
your knob
is they have is a typical interaction
matching and our model
yes no not for attitude it's a
multiplicative
yeah yeah the multiplicative model
explains the data yes
exactly yes
sorry with the data generated so far
have you had any early glimpses into how
cell type specific the data might be
either like reporting your system for
another cell line or some of the other
data that's out there with like
commentarial dispersions
um
a lot of the data that are out there are
kind of bio process specific and so we
have we can do some
comparisons there we've
tried to compare to the depth map to see
if we can get any clues about background
effects so yeah we're doing that um
i don't have any overall conclusion for
you okay what was the question i was
just wondering if there was if you had
any like early indications as to how
i think probably because of the types of
query genes we're choosing they're
probably not going to be that cell type
specific and as i just said we have
taken the subset of genes that we've got
genetic interaction profiles up fairly
early on and tested them in other cell
lines and they seem to
reoccur in other cell lines
but yeah hopefully we can look at our
data maybe and
perhaps start to predict what what sort
of modules you might have to use in
another cell background to just to
explore
yeah
we're gonna update it
so i assume that all screens are based
on
genes not transcripts so we are not
looking at you know what
alternatives
is
um
we're suggesting it's a measurement of
the relative growth rates in the
population so again it's a population
growth assay it's instead of an earning
based assay but yes we're
inferring
a growth phenotype from the guide
abundance
so um
we will
they have done some of that um
trioticuslab has also done some nice
work looking at dna damage networks etc
and
you do so what we try to do is sample
the space we can't do that experiment
over and over again in many conditions
so we took what we knew from study
making the big network and design a much
smaller array that gives us most of the
information and that way we could test
condition specific single mutant effects
and bellamy effects
and most of the time you see the
interaction in the reference condition
and it's exacerbated or suppressed in
some other condition you do see a set of
things that you didn't detect the
records but by and large most of it is
there in the reference network so again
we find that
encouraging in terms of thinking about
reference networks
which trade um good keyword
a couple of years ago he developed this
classifier for cancer um cells using
transcriptomes and all kinds of networks
that was oriented at the genetology
treatment
and i think one thing that
emerged while he was doing those
experiments that he needed to propose
new gene ontology categories and terms
and i was wondering if you see evidence
for those
in your gene ontology annotation of the
clusters that you see in the human
center
and then we load a box for the height